Hello everybody, I'm Luca from Luca Lampariello.com
and this time not only am I speaking Spanish,
but I'm with a very special person by the name of Pablo.
Pablo, how are you? Hello Luca! How are you?
Very well! Very well in Rome. I don't know if it's hot
in...where are you now, in Barcelona?
I'm in Thailand, so you can imagine how hot it is.
Yes, I can imagine!
Then, Pablo, could you introduce yourself to
my audience? Maybe, I don't know, some of them surely
already know you, but perhaps others do not.  So could you tell me about what you do in life? And also, I know you're a polyglot
so you can tell me a little about your experience as a polyglot?
Yes, well, I am the creator of the YouTube channel
Dreaming Spanish, for people who are learning Spanish, and well, at one point in my life, a
few years ago I realized that you could learn
languages in a much better way, and then later
after a couple
of failed projects, of failed attempts to help
people I realized that is that there was a
need for comprehensible content
That there is no content easy enough to understand for
someone to start learning a language from zero
In the way that it works, in the way that science, that research
tells us that we really acquire vocabulary,
we acquire grammar, so after having learned
several languages, having learned English,
French, and Japanese, I decided to apply what
I had learned to help other people and I started
with Spanish because it is the language I
speak as a native speaker, but in the future
I would also like to expand
And to do and apply the same concept but in
other languages. Very well, and what is this
massive input? I mean, not massive input...comprehensible
input, and then we can talk about massive input
so could you give me a concrete definition
or a concrete example of what comprehensible input is
because Stephen Krashen who is a famous
linguist who introduced this concept, but
concretely, for example, if you...what would you
advise a person who starts speaking Spanish
What kind of material would he have to choose?
And then, a person who already has, let's say, an intermediate base in Spanish
How would you advise them and how does the definition
of comprehensible input change according to
the level you have in a foreign language?
Well, comprehensible input
is two words. One is input, and you have to
understand that input is something you hear
or read. You have to be listening or reading. Speaking
and doing exercises is not input,
that's the first thing. And the second thing
is that it is comprehensible; you understand
it. Understanding it does not mean you understand
the logical reasoning, that you understand the rules
of grammar. It means you understand the message
that is being communicated by what you are
hearing or what you are reading, so once you
understand what that person is trying to communicate
is when you start to associate those words
you are hearing or reading with the meaning
thanks to the knowledge you already have or
the context or the rest of the words in that
text or in that video you are watching, so
what you are saying about what it means at
each level, is that this idea that I
just explained can be applied to all levels,
what happens is that when you start from scratch
if someone starts talking to you, all the
words, if you start from scratch, you don't
know any of the words, right? Whatever happens, there are going to be a lot of words
that you are not really going to
understand exactly what they are referring
to and when you start when you start learning
the language it's more like linking together, little
by little, all the words that contain the most meaning,
that have the most important meaning, and you
need something that is very easy to understand,
you really need to be talking about something
that you are seeing, that they are showing
you a cup, and they tell you "cup", something that is really
very obvious, right? Then, yeah, at the lower levels
it's mostly this, that you are noticing
that there are certain words that are used
in certain situations, and you start to link  them
at higher levels and especially when you start reading, the way
you can acquire new words, is because you know
enough of the context you know enough of the
other words that appear in that text, for example
and in this case, the case of learning vocabulary
and grammar by reading,  the research that has
been done so far points out that the maximum
speed of learning by reading is when you already
understand or already know 98% of the words
that appear in the text. Or rather, only one
word out of 50 that you do not know. This is
a much easier kind of reading
than most people think of. Many people think that
it has to be difficult, that if it is not
difficult what you are doing, you
are not learning, right?
Very well explained, I think
that for me the comprehensible input is
input that you can understand, that you are
in the middle of understanding, like for example videos where there are
subtitles. Nowadays, it's possible to watch videos
read videos in two languages
not only, for example, for your videos in Spanish, but there are tools that allow you to
translate directly, to have a translation
this, to me, is comprehensible input in the sense that you can
see, understand, listen, and also
directly read, a text with audio, something
that you can read and listen, and also, maybe, you could translate it
so that you have the translation
this is comprehensible input, but also for me it's important and I think in this sense
I think you do
a hell of a job, the sense of comprehensible input is important, it's
it's necessary but it's not enough
because the most important thing is also
that this comprehensible input is something that you like
we are used to in school to do things that we don't like,
you remember in school.
that they gave us things we didn't care about at all, and
now we live in this information age
where we can choose things, like
what I like about your website, you have
a site and a YouTube channel, we're going to
talk about that at the end, but in general what I
like is that you've, let's say, you've created a system
where you have content for "Super Beginners", I
like the concept of "Super Beginner", "Beginner", so
you have various possibilities for it to be
very diversified, and you have possibilities
for beginners, those who have an intermediate
level and even those with advanced level,
and if I'm not mistaken, you also have, for example,
history lessons, little things about history,
interesting content. I was wondering
how you got the idea to create this site,
and why you created this site.
Well, the idea of teaching a language without teaching the language,
but teaching something else, but using the language
well, it's something that's been used in other situations as well,
but mostly the method
that I use is based on a school in Bangkok
where Thai is taught, and in fact I spent
one year in this school learning Thai
myself, because the method they use fit
very much with my experiences when I learned
English and Japanese, and I wanted to try it. For me it was a
experiment, I came here one year and I wanted to see how well
I learned Thai, and it worked very well for me.
so I decided to adapt the method they use in this
this school to the online world so that millions of
of people can benefit, not only the 30 people that fit in a class, right?
Great! And we talked for a second about massive input,
comprehensible input, we said comprehensible and
And interesting input, it's super important, but if
someone "old school" asks you
"Well, how can you learn a language without learning
grammar?" What would you say to him?
For example, he says  "Okay, comprehensible input, but I don't understandthe subjunctive, or how it's used"
I know that English speakers, and foreigners in general
have a lot of problems with the subjunctive
Italians have a little less trouble with the subjunctive, because it's a
very similar structure in the two languages, but
How do you respond to a person who says "No, no,
I like grammar, I'm used to learning
grammar, how could you teach me grammar without
teaching it to me?" Well, how I
explain it is that at no time has it been shown
that rationally learning the
rules of grammar is useful for acquiring
grammar, useful for understanding it in a way...
Like intuition...an intuitive way and that you can use it in
conversation without having to think about the
structures that you're using, and without having to think about
thinking about the grammar, and having to stop to
make sure you're saying it right, and yet what the research does show
that's been done so far, is that adults can continue to learn howchildren learn.
Children learn the grammar of their native language,
they learn to use it withoutanyone having
explained the rules to them. Children, when they start school at the age of six, they already speak their own language.
They are already native speakers of the language, and up to that point, they've never been taught grammar before.
And my personal experience is that I, too, have
learned more than one language in this way, without
ever having learned the rules of grammar,
but still I have the "feeling", I have the intuition of
how to use what is correct, and what is not correct.
Very well, and it istrue. This is based
in science. For example, I always, let's say, I always had
this intuition...we have this intuition, people that learn
languages, we realize that the brain learns,
there's a "brain-friendly" way,
as they say in English, and a way that
is not very "brain-friendly", that doesn't adapt much
to the way our brain learns, and
one of the things that they've discovered is that
grammar rules, if you want to deliberately teach
the rules of grammar, this doesn't
work, because in our brain there are two parts
that are dedicated to...one is dedicated to so-called
"declarative memory" and the other is...I think in
I think in Spanish it's called "procedimental" (procedural) I thought
The Spanish word was "procedural", butI looked it up in Wikipedia
and it's "procedimental", and declarative memory has
to do with the facts, with the things that you know, with
the rules of grammar that you know, a separate thing,
procedural memory is what we know how to do, or
procedures. Speaking a language, our own
native language, has to do with
procedural memory that processes, let's say,
the way we work with information, and say one
word after the other, and we're just
sabotaging ourselves, when at school we learn in a way
that's not very natural, so
I'm convinced, like you, that you learn a
foreign language the way you learn your native language
there are many other linguists, there are two
categories of linguists those who believe that it is
the same process, and those who don't, but
other than that, I'm with you, I agree with you about the
fact that you can learn grammar in a way that is,
let's say, indirect and a little bit direct, let's say,
it depends on the language, but fundamentally, one learns...
It's better to learn, let's say,
grammar through massive input, because our brain
learns so much in this way
Okay, we've talked a little bit about grammar through massive input,
Let's talk a little about...you teach Spanish
so you have a lot of experience with what they ask you,
with what your audience asks you.
What are the biggest linguistic difficulties or obstacles
that one of the...
of the English-speaking world and foreigners ingeneral?
And the beliefs...you know, when talking about
language learning, there are people who say
you have to move to a new country to learn a new language.
and, I don't know, so (what are) the obstacles,
the difficulties, and beliefs in general?
So yeah, these are all preconceptions based on
traditional language teaching, right? And a lot of things
about the way languages are taught are
based on how dead languages were taught,
the way Latin and Ancient Greek were taught, and
many other things are based on
in Skinner's Behaviorism, on the fact that
by doing one thing and repeating it, you get used to doing it
this way, and then you're always going to do it this way, and
and that's why we think we have to
practice, we have to do drills until we get it right,
that they have to correct us, we have to have these
good and bad experiences, and learn
from the good ones and so on, right? Meanwhile this has
never been shown to work for languages. So
it comes from there. That's why people think that they have
they have to learn the rules, they have to understand
why you use this tense, when you use this verb tense
and when you use another, how, I don't know,
in Spanish, you use "Se" ("if"),
the subjunctive mood, the different types of past tense,
a lot of people think that this is necessary.
People want to know the translation for
the words, for them, they want to know how
this word is said in their language. But then,
often, the words either don't have a translation
or when you translate them, you're actually learning things
that are not true, because a lot of times, even though
they are words that come from the same origin,
they cover different ranges of meaning, right?
And by learning them as translations, I think you
can also end up having an incorrect idea
of the meaning and the situations in which
those words can be used.
Yes, normally, when people ask me,
or when people don't understand something about
way we teach, it's because of this, because
they have these preconceptions
of the traditional method of teaching languages.
And difficulties? So with
difficulties, has it happened to you,
for example that you met these
people who demotivate themselves? And how do you do it,
motivating yourself as a polyglot, and how do you
teach others how to motivate themselves? Because I think
it's possible to motivate someone, but it's
not going to last a long time.
People always talk about motivation, because
I think, at the end of the day, the ones who get there, who
speak a language fluently are those who
do it, learn it, in a long...let's say as
a long term project, so regarding motivation
What do you suggest to people when they get
demotivated, and they think this is too hard?
because I noticed that the ones that get demotivated the most are
also those who have never learned to...
have never learned a language fluently, and so
they're not sure that they're going to get it.
Well, yeah, motivation is a huge issue, isn't it?
So, motivation, everything that applies as far as
to motivation in general, to any goal or
objective that you want to achieve
also applies to languages. The fact of showing
people a clear path that they have to follow
in order to get there, right? The fact that people believe in
you, believe that you know what you're talking about.
It's like you say, if the person has had experience with
learning a language, they already know that they can do it.
It's going to be much more difficult for them to lose
motivation, because they already believe in themselves
If they've never done it, one way you can help them
is by showing them examples of other people
of people as similar to them as possible.
They may come from the same country, they may come from
the same social class and everything, well, they will believe you
much more and they're going to be more motivated. All these are
things that apply to motivation in general, right?
For any goal that you want to achieve.
The fact that you're seeing progress because of this. but then
there are things that apply specifically to
languages, and in the case of languages,
I think it's important to set students up with the
right expectations. And this is something that I think
traditional language teaching doesn't do very well.
Because when you go to a language class,
they give you a vocabulary list. They teach you some
grammar points. You go home, and you think okay,
look, I've come this far, we've finished
topic one of the book, and you've made all this progress.
And then you finish course 2, or 3, or whatever it is that
the school offers, and when people finish all
the courses in a language school, they still can't
speak fluently. But they've already finished all the subject matter,
and they've finished all the grammar
that is easy to explain, that is easy to go over, and
to check on a test that they have learned it
and I think that this is what produces what they call
"the plateau", the place where a lot of people stay.
and then they feel like they're not moving forward. I think it's because of this, because they've been using the
rational part of their brain to learn
the rules of grammar, and this has given them some
very high expectations. They believe that the speed of
learning should be this fast, and
they have to keep learning at this speed. While
the speed at which they have been really acquiring
language, at which their subconscious, or the more intuitive part
of the brain has been learning, has been
slower and it's going to continue to be slower, because
that's the actual speed at which they're learning language.
And I think setting correct expectations
from the beginning, that this is going to be ongoing,
that acquiring language is going to happen little by little,
that you're not even going to completely learn one
word today. Today, maybe you'll be able to associate it with
one example where you've heard it, when you've heard it in
a situation where it was referring to a specific thing.
But today, you've learned 1% of this word
you are going to have to hear it many more times, right?
Then I think it's important to set
these expectations so that people won't be disappointed
and think that they're not making progress.
Very good answer! I always tell my
students when they ask me, for example
They ask me all the time: "When I am going to get a B2 or a C1?" and they are worried about goals.
I always tell them to concentrate on the system, on
habits, because the truth is that speaking
a language is a marathon. If you want to speak a language
language well, with fluency, and know the nuances of
the culture and all of that, this takes years.
It's going to take you years. And if you already know
that you've got a long road ahead of you,
you're going to relax and you're going to enjoy the journey.
So that's why I say if you worry, it's very important to set
expectations, to clearly explain that it's going
to take years. But you can make progress, and this
doesn't mean that you can't talk, that you have to
wait years before you can talk. You can talk!
But you have to concentrate on the journey. One
last question...I could clearly talk for hours
but for obvious reasons, we have to come to the end
of this conversation, this very interesting chat
(The question is) to speak from the beginning, or wait (to speak)?
That is, if, for example someone starts
learning Spanish today, how would you advise them? To start
from zero? To speak right away, because the
sooner, the better? Or to wait for months or
years before talking, because if you get more input
then it's going to be easier afterwards. Which school of thought
do you belong to? Waiting, waiting, of course. Yes,
based on the science that there is about it,
there's actually not much and there's less of it than we need.
I think that more research needs to be done on the subject, but
there are some articles that show that people
who write less, that talk less, they get
better scores on tests that actually measure
language acquisition. Then there are people
who are introverted, and who we can assume
speak less, obtain better accents in
the language they are learning than extroverted
people, right? And this is something that hasn't been
100% proven, and in the future we need
to have more studies done.
And, well, another reason is that in general, I accept that
to learn a language well, (you must) do it the way a child does it
Then, if we have some reason to change something, if we believe that something can be improved, then we can see if it
can be improved. But by default, kids do it well
and reach a very good final result.
And children have what we call the "Silent Period".
the period in which they don't talk, which happens both in
babies, who don't use a lot of words that
they can already understand, and it also happens that
children who move away, who go to live in another country,
they usually go for months without saying
anything in the language that is spoken in that place,  and
then one day, all of a sudden, they start to say things, and they start to talk, right?
This fits in very much also with Krashen's
theory, that in the end it's the input, it's
what we receive, and not what we say.
And there's also a practical part to this.
To try talking when you don't know how...it's painful, it's difficult.
And, well, for a lot of people it's not an agreeable experience
But the more input you have received,
the more you've acquired, the easier it's going to be
to talk, and begin to talk, right?
I more or less agree with you, I've also tried
to talk a little earlier, but I always wait
months before speaking, and that fits a lot
with my experience, with yours, and with Krashen's.
But well if a person wants to talk earlier
because, I don't know, they need to for work,
well, everyone is different, everyone has
different existential circumstances, and well, the world's an
amazing place because there's a bit of everything.
Yes, yes, of course, in practice you have to
choose, to see what are your values, what
is the most important, and do what
is going to be best for you. Of course!
Pablo, it's been a blast, thank you very much.
A blast to speak with you, a pleasure, and could you tell our
viewers where they can find you, and then afterwards, I will
put the links in the description box as well.
Yes, come to the YouTube channel "Dreaming Spanish"
where we have content for all levels
like Luca said, we teach history, there are
videos where I play video games,
we have Latin American teachers too,
and then we are working on our website
that in the future we want to turn into
a learning platform where you can really
learn starting from scratch and get to
basically any level, to at least a
level that, if you'd prefer, I don't know, to go watch Netflix,
go watch movies, go talk to people on
the language, then we can to take you up to that level. And yeah,
that's it. Phenomenal! Thank you very much, Pablo and
have a great time in Thailand! Thanks to you for inviting me.
See you soon, ciao!